the new hot thing among some republicans  including marjorie taylor green is  taking on ssris ssris are a class of  anti uh antidepressant and anti-anxiety  drugs many of them have been around for  decades and decades and are some of the  most studied and tested  drugs out there this is becoming popular  where now a lot of the anti-backs people  are going after ssris part of the reason  is they want to blame ssris rather than  guns for shootings i have talked about  this in detail  extensively on my youtube channel  youtube.com slash the david pakman show  make sure you're following me there and  let me know in a comment once they're  done with ssris what will they go to  next vitamin water coconut water